[Applause]
the Ukrainian president receives a
hero's welcome as he enters
the house rule that men must wear a
jacket and tie waved or simply not
enforced
the invitation to address both houses of
Congress is a rare honor but the
Ukrainian president is also well aware
that the legislators here control
American Purse strings and it is there
he has to persuade to continue Aid to
his country thank you for both Financial
packages you have already provided us
with and the ones you may be willing to
decide on your money is not charity
it's an investment in the global
security and democracy that we handle in
the most responsible way
this is one of the last occasions how
speaker Nancy Pelosi will preside over
the Chamber from January the 3rd it will
be a republican in the chair with some
on the right wing of the party intent on
stopping the regular funding to Ukraine
the extreme right-wing faction is very
much in the minority but with the slim
Republican majority in the house its
power is disproportionate to its size
and the issue of Ukrainian funding could
prove to be a factor even in the
election of a house Speaker earlier the
Ukrainian president arrived at the White
House ushered in by President Biden who
put an arm around his shoulders and who
made clear that unequivocal U.S support
will continue the American people have
been with you every step of the way and
we will stay with you we will stay with
you for as long as it takes on this day
2 the Senate overwhelmingly confirmed a
new ambassador to Russia
it has also sent a massive Omnibus bull
to the house which includes an
additional funding of more than 40
billion dollars for Ukraine
at the conclusion of his speech the
Ukrainian president presented a Battle
Flag signed by soldiers to the outgoing
house speaker
a flag that he said is a symbol of
victory
and the Applause is a clear signal that
Ukraine and its president are assured of
ongoing bipartisan support
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington